the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so last time we saw things about
gradients and directional derivatives
before that we've studied how to look
for minimal and maximal functions of
several variables and today we're going
to look again and min/max problems but
in a different setting namely when the
variables are not independent and so
what we'll see is the method of LaGrange
multipliers and this is the one point in
the term when I can shine with my french
accent and say let one's named Holly
okay so what are LaGrange multipliers
about well the goal is to minimize or
maximize a function of several variables
let's say for example f of XY Z
variables but where these variables are
no longer independent
so they're not independent that means
that there's a relation between them the
relation is maybe some equation of the
form G of X Y Z equals some constant
okay so you take the relation between X
Y Z you call that G and that gives you
the constraint and the goal is to
minimize F only above those values of
XYZ that satisfy the constraint so
what's one way to do that well one way
to do that if the constraint is very
simple we can maybe solve from one of
the variables okay maybe we can solve
this equation for one of the variables
plug back into F and then we have a
usual min max problem that we've seen
how to do the problem is sometimes you
can't actually solve for X Y Z in here
because this condition is too
complicated and when we need a new
method and that's what we are going to
do okay so why would we care about that
well one example is actually in physics
maybe you've seen in thermodynamics that
you study quantities about gases and
those quantities that involve pressure
volume and temperature and pressure
volume and temperature are not
independent of each other I mean you
know probably the equation PV equals NRT
and of course where you could actually
solve to express things in terms of one
of the other but sometimes it's more
convenient to really keep all three
variables but treat them as constraint
so that's just an example of a situation
where you might want to do this
anyway we look mostly at mathematical
examples but just to point out that this
is useful when you study guesses in
physics so the first observation is we
can't use our usual method of looking
for critical points of F because
critical points of F typically they will
not satisfy this condition so they want
to be good solutions we need something
else okay so well let's look at an
example and we'll see how that leads us
to the method okay so for example let's
say that I want to find the point
closest to the origin on on the
hyperbola XY equals 3 in the plane okay
so that means I have this hyperbola and
I'm asking myself what's the point on it
that's the closest to the origin I mean
we can solve this by elementary geometry
we don't need actually like our
multipliers but we are going to do it
with Lagrange multipliers because it's a
pretty good example so what does it mean
well it means really we want to minimize
distance to the origin so what's the
distance to the origin if I have a point
at coordinates X Y then the distance to
the origin is square root of x squared
plus y squared well do we really want to
minimize that or can we minimize
something easier yeah maybe we can
minimize the square of a distance
okay so let's forget this guy and
instead
so actually will minimize f of XY equals
x squared plus y squared that looks that
now subject to the constraint X y equals
3 and so we'll call this tank G of XY
okay
to illustrate the general method so
let's look at a picture so here you can
see in yellow the hyperbola XY equals 3
and we're going to look for the points
that are closest to the origin so what
can we do well for example we can plot
the function x squared plus y squared is
an F that's the contour plot of F with a
hyperbola on top of it and now let's see
what we can do with that well let's ask
ourselves for example if I look at
points that are where F equals 20 now I
think I'm at 20 that you can't really
see it that's a circle at the point
whose distance square is 20 well can I
find a solution if I'm on the hyperbola
yes there are four points at this
distance
okay can I do better well let's decrease
the distance yes we can still find
points on the hyperbola and so on well
except if we go too low then there's no
points on this circle anymore on the
hyperbola so if we decrease the value of
F that we want to look at there's
somehow a limit value beyond which we
can't go and that's the minimum of F
okay so we're trying to look for the
smallest value of F that will actually
be realized on the hyperbola so when
does that happen well I have to back
like a little bit it seems like the
limiting case is basically here it's
when the circle is tangent to the
hyperbola that's the smallest circle
that will hit the hyperbola
okay so if I take a larger value of F I
will have solutions if I take a smaller
value of F I will not have any solutions
anymore so that's the situation that we
want to solve okay so how do we find
that minimum well if a key observation
that's valid on this picture and that
actually will remain true in the
completely general case is that when we
have a minimum the level curl the level
curve of F is actually tangent to our
hyperbola its tangent to our constraint
into the set of points where X y equals
weight to the hyper ball okay so let's
write that down observe we observe that
at the minimum the level curve of F is
tangent to the hyperbola and remember
the hyperbola is given by the equation G
equals 3 so it's a level curve of G okay
so we have a level curve of F and the
level curve of G but our tangent to each
other and I claim that's going to be the
general situation that we are interested
in so how do we look for you know try to
solve for points where this happens
so how do we find XY where the level
curves of F and G are tangent to each
other
well so let's think for a second if the
two level curves are tangent to each
other that means that they have the same
tangent line right if you have a same
tangent line that means that the normal
vectors should be parallel okay let me
maybe draw a picture here so this is the
level curve maybe F equals something and
this is the level curve G equals
constant here my constant is free well
if I look at the gradient vectors so the
gradient of F will be perpendicular to
the level curve of F the gradient of G
will be perpendicular to the level curve
of G we don't have any reason to be of
the same size okay but we have to be
parallel to each other of course they
could also be parallel pointing in
opposite directions mean but the key
point is that when this happens
the gradient of f is parallel to the
gradient of G well let's check that okay
so here's a point and I can plot the
gradient of F in blue the gradient of G
in yellow and you see in most of these
places somehow the two gradients are not
really parallel actually I shouldn't be
looking at random points if you'd be
looking only on the hyperbola right I
want points on the hyperbola where we
took gradients are parallel well when
does that happen
hmm looks like it will happen here okay
so see when I'm at the minimum the two
gradient vectors are parallel okay
that's it's not really a proof it's an
example that seems to be convincing so
far things work pretty well okay so how
do we decide if two vectors are parallel
well they're parallel when they're
proportional to each other so you can
write one of them as a constant times
the other one and that constant usually
one uses the Greek letter lambda okay I
don't know if you've seen it before it's
a great letter of L and probably I'm
sure that somebody somebody's idea of
paying a tribute to Lagoon
you know by putting an L in there okay
so lambda is just a constant and we are
looking for a scalar lambda and point x
and y where this holds so in fact what
we are doing is we are replacing min max
problem in two variables with a
constraint between them by a set of
equations involving you will see three
variables so we have min max with two
variables x and y but not independent we
had a constraint
G of X y equals constant and that
becomes something new that becomes a
system of equations where we have to
solve well so let's write down what it
means for gradient F to be proportional
to gradient G that means that F sub X
should be lambda times G sub X and F sub
y should be lambda times G sub y right
because the gradient vectors here are F
sub X F sub y and G sub X G sub y if you
have a third variable Z then you have
also an equation F sub Z equals lambda G
sub Z now let's see how many unknowns do
we have in these equations well there's
X does Y and does lambda so we have
three unknowns we have only two
equations something's missing well yeah
I mean x and y are not actually
independent they are related by the
equation G of X y equals C so we need to
add the constraint G equals C and now we
have three equations involving three
variables okay let's see how that works
so here remember we have F equals x
squared plus y squared and G equals XY
okay so what's F sub X that's going to
be 2x equals lambda times what is G sub
X Y okay so maybe I should write here F
sub x equals lambda G sub X just to
remind you then we have F sub y equals
lambda G sub y why does that what so f
sub y is 2 y equals lambda times G sub y
is X and then our third equation G
equals C becomes X y equals 3 okay so
that's what we would have to solve ok
any questions at this point no yes
how do I know the direction of the
gradient do you mean how do I know that
it's perpendicular to the level curve oh
how do I know whether it points in that
direction on the opposite one well that
depends I mean we've seen actually less
time but the gradient is perpendicular
to the level and points towards higher
values of a function so it could be with
where did I have M yeah it could be that
my gradient vectors they're actually
point in opposite directions it doesn't
matter to me because it will still look
the same in terms of the equation just
lambda will be positive or negative
depending on the case okay so I can
handle both situations it's not a
problem so I can allow lambda to be
positive or negative and well in this
example it looks like lambda will be
positive if you look at the picture on
the on the plot yes well because
actually they are not equal to each
other if you look at you know so if you
look at this point where the hyperbola
and the circle touch each other so first
of all I don't know which circle I'm
going to look at right I'm trying to
solve actually for the radius of the
circle and try to find what's the
minimum value of F and second add value
of F actually the value at that point
the value of F and the value of G are
not equal right G is equal to three
because I'm on the hyperbola x y equals
three the value of f will be the square
of a distance whatever that is I think
it will end up being six but we'll see
okay so you can't really set them equal
because you don't know what F is equal
to in advance yes
I'm fine
not white no we're not
so I mean actually here I'm just using
this idea of you know finding a point
closest to the origin to illustrate an
example of a min max problem the general
problem they're trying to solve is
minimize f subject to G equals constant
and what we are going to do for that is
we are very going to say instead let's
look at places where gradient F and
gradient G are parallel to each other
and solve for equations of that I think
we completely lose the notion of closest
point if we you know just look at these
equations we don't really say anything
about closest points anymore of course
that's what they mean in the end but in
the general setting there's no closest
point involved anymore just that yes yes
so it's always going to be the case that
at a minimum or at the maximum of a
function subject to a constraint the
level curves of F and the level curves
of G will be tangent to each other so
that's the basis for this method okay so
I'm going to justify that soon so yes it
could be minimum or maximum Oh in three
dimensions it could even be a saddle
point and in fact I should say in
advance this method will not tell us
whether it's a minimum or maximum we
don't have any way of knowing
except for testing values we can't use
second derivative test or anything like
that
okay I'll get back to that yes
yes here you can set y equals to favor X
and then you can minimize x squared plus
9 over x squared in general you know if
I'm trying to solve a more complicated
problem I might not be able to solve ok
so I'm doing an example where indeed
here you could solve and remove one
variable but you can't always do that
and this method will still work we have
an amount okay I don't see any other
questions are there any other questions
okay
then I see a lot of uses and stretching
and so on so it's very confusing for me
but ok so how do we solve these
equations well the answer is in general
we might be in deep trouble
ok there's no general method for solving
the equations that you get from this
method you just have to think about them
and so you know sometimes it will be
very easy sometimes it will be so hard
that you can't actually do it without a
computer sometimes it will be just hard
enough to be on top B of this week's
problem set
okay so in this case I claim in this
case we can actually do it without so
much trouble okay
because actually we can think of this as
a two by two linear system in X&Y well
let me let me do something okay so let
me rewrite the first two equations as 2x
minus lambda y equals zero and lambda X
minus 2y equals zero and X y equals
three
alright that's what we want to solve
well I can put this into matrix form two
minus lambda lambda minus 2 times X y
equals zero now how do I solve a linear
system matrix times X y equals zero well
I always have an obvious solution ok x
and y both equal to zero is that a good
solution no because the whole time zero
is not free okay so we want another
solution so that radial solution zero
zero does not solve the constraint
equation X y equals three so we want
another solution when do we have another
solution
well when the determinant of the matrix
is zero so we have other solutions exist
only if the determinant of the matrix is
zero and where m is this K okay so let's
compute the determinant
well that seems to be negative 4 plus
lambda squared so that's zero exactly
when lambda square equals 4 which is
lambda is plus or minus 2 okay
so already you see here it's at the
level of difficulty that's a little bit
much for an exam but perfectly fine for
a problem set of a beautiful lecture
like this one okay so how do we deal
with well we have two cases to look at
lambda equals to lambda equals -2 let's
start with lambda equals 2 if I set
lambda equals 2 where does that what
does this equation become well becomes x
equals y this one becomes y equals x
well they seem to be the same okay x
equals y and then the equation x y
equals 3 becomes well X square equals 5
so I have two solutions one is x equals
root 3 and that for what y equals would
fail as well
Oh negative 3 negative root 3 let's look
at the other case well if I set lambda
equal to negative 2 then I get 2x equals
negative 2 y that means x equals
negative Y the second one 2 y equals
negative 2x that's y equals negative x
well that's the same thing and x y
equals 3 becomes well negative x squared
equals 5
can we solve that no okay
so there's no solutions here so now we
have to candidate points which are these
two points would favor three are
negative or a negative or three
okay so let's actually look at what we
have here well maybe you can't read
recordin eights but actually the point
that I have here is indeed would favor
three and how do we see that lambda
equals two well if you look at this
picture the gradient of F that's the
blue vector is indeed twice the yellow
vector gradient G that's where you read
for value of lambda and we have the
other solution which is somewhere here
negative or a negative would three and
there again lambda equals two the two
vectors are proportional by a factor of
two yes
no solutions are not quite guaranteed to
be absolute minimum or maximum a
guaranteed to be somehow critical points
under the constraint that means you know
if you were able to solve and eliminate
variable they would be critical points
so when you have the same problem as
with critical points of a maxima or
minima and the answer is well we won't
know until we check okay more questions
no yes so what is a Lagrange multiplier
well it's this number lambda is called
the multiplier here okay
it's multiplier because it's what you
have to multiply a gradient of G by to
get gradient of F you know it multiplies
okay so okay so let's try to see why is
this method valid because you know so
far I've shown you pictures and I said
well see they're tangent but why is it
that they have to be tangent in general
okay so let's think about it let's say
that we are at the constraint min or max
so what that means is that if I move on
the level G equals constant then the
value of F should only increase or only
decrease but it means in particular to
first order it will not change okay
that's worse you know that's so at an
unconstrained minima the partial
derivatives are zero in this case the
derivatives are zero only in the allowed
directions and the allowed directions
are those that stay on the on the level
surface G equals constant okay so in any
direction along the level set G we'll
see the rate of change of F
must be zero that's what happens at
minima Maxima except here of course we
look only at the allowed directions okay
so let's say the same thing in terms of
directional derivatives
so that means for any direction that's
tangent to the constraint level G equals
C we must have D F D s in the direction
of U equals zero okay we maybe draw a
picture so let's say now I mean three
variables just to you know give you
different examples so here I have a
level surface G equals C I'm at my point
and if I move in any direction that on
the level surface so I move in the
direction u that tangent to the level
surface then the rate of change of F in
that direction should be zero now
remember what's the formula for this guy
well we've seen that this guy is
actually gradient F dot u so that means
any such vector u must be perpendicular
to the variant of F
well so that means that the gradient of
F should be perpendicular to anything
that's tangent to this level so that
means the gradient of F should be
perpendicular to the level set that's
what we've shown
but we know another vector that's also
perpendicular to the level set of G that
the gradient of G so we conclude that
the gradient of F must be parallel to
the gradient of G because both are
perpendicular to the level set of G okay
I see confused faces so let me try to
tell you again where that comes from
so we said if we have a constant minimum
or maximum if we move in the level set
of G F doesn't change
well doesn't change to first order
remember it's the same idea as when
you're looking for a minimum you set the
derivative equal to zero okay so the
derivative in any direction tangent to G
equals C should be the directional
derivative of F in any such direction
should be zero that's what we mean by a
critical point of F and so that means
that any vector U you had any unit
vector tangent to the level set of G is
going to be perpendicular to the
gradient of F so that means that the
gradient of F is perpendicular to the
level set of G if you want that means
the level sets of F and G are tangent to
each other okay so that's justifying
what we've observed on the picture that
the two level sets have to be tangent to
each other at the constraint minimum or
maximum
does that make a little bit of sense
and I see at least a few pieces nothing
so I take that four and think that to be
a positive answer okay so since I've
been asked by several of you how do I
know if it's a maximum or a minimum well
warning the method doesn't tell whether
a solution is a minimum or a maximum so
how do we do it well
no bad news we can't use the second
derivative test and the reason for that
is that we care actually only about
these specific directions that are
tangent to available of G and we don't
really I mean we don't want to bother to
try to define directional second
derivatives not to mention that actually
it wouldn't work there is a criterion
but it's much more complicated than that
so basically the answer for us is we
don't have a second derivative test in
this situation so what are we left with
well we're just left with comparing
values you know say that in this problem
you found a point where F equals three a
point where F equals nine a point where
F equals fifteen well then probably the
minimum is the point where F equals
three and the maximum is 15 actually in
this case well we found minimum you know
these two points are tied for minimum
what about the maximum what's the
maximum of F and the hyperbola
well it's infinity because we you know
the point can go as far as you want from
the origin so but the general idea is if
we have a good reason to believe that
there should be a minimum and you know
what it's not like at infinity
or something weird like that then the
minimum will be a solution of the
Lagrange multiplier equations so we just
look for all the solutions and then we
choose the one that gives us the lowest
value is that good enough okay so let me
actually write it down just
so
to find the minimum or the maximum we
compare the values of F at the various
solutions to the Lagrange multiplier
equations to American equations
okay let's do well sorry I should say
also sometimes you can just conclude you
know by thinking geometrically I mean in
this case you know when it's asking you
which point is closest to the origin you
can just see that your answer is the
correct one okay let's do an advanced
example advanced means that well this
one I didn't actually dare to put on top
B of the problem set
since then I'm going to do it okay so
what is this going to be about we're
going to look for a surface minimizing
pyramid okay so let's say that we want
to build a pyramid with a given
triangular base and a given volume and
so say that you know I have maybe in the
XY plane I'm giving you some triangle
and I'm going to try to build a pyramid
so I have to find where to put because I
can choose where to put the top of a
pyramid this guy will end up being
behind now
and the constraint and the goal is to
minimize the total surface area okay
so first time I told this class that was
like a few years ago it was just before
they built the Stata Center and then I
used to motivate this problem by saying
well fine gear has gone crazy and he's
given a triangular plot of land he wants
to put a pyramid there needs to be the
right amount of volume so that you can
put all the offices in there and he
wants it to be actually you know covered
in solid gold and because that's
expensive the MIT administration wants
him to cut the costs of it and so you
have to minimize the total sides so that
it doesn't cost too much
we'll see if MIT comes up with the
triangular pyramid building hopefully
not could be our next dome in the value
okay anyway it's it's a fine geometry
problem and let's try to think about you
know how we can do this so the natural
way to think about it would be well what
we have to look for first what do we
have to look for we have to look of a
position of that top point well remember
we know that the volume of a pyramid is
one-third of area of the base times
height okay so in fact fixing the volume
knowing that we have fixed the area of a
base means that we're fixing the height
of the pyramid okay so the height is
completely fixed what we have to choose
just is where do we put that top point
do we put it smack in the middle of a
triangle or to a side or even you know
anywhere we want but it's Z coordinate
is fixed okay let's call H right so what
we could do is something like this we
say well we have three points in the
base let's call them P 1 X 1 Y 1 0 P 2
at X 2 y 2 0 P 3 at X Phi Y Phi 0 this
point P is the unknown point at X Y H
well this we know the height and then we
want to minimize the sum of the areas of
these three triangles that are in one
here one here and one at the back and
areas of triangles we know how to
express using lengths of course length
of cross-product so that becomes a
function of x and y and you can try to
minimize it
and actually it doesn't quite work the
formulas are just too complicated you
never get there
so what happens is actually maybe we
need better coordinates why do we need
better coordinates that's because the
geometry is kind of difficult to do if
you use X Y coordinates
I mean formula for cross-product is fine
but when the length of a vector will be
annoying and just doesn't look good
so instead let's think about it
differently oh I have one more bolt
okay so if I claim if we do it this way
you know when we express when the area
as a function of XY
well actually we can solve a minimum of
a minimum so here's another way to do it
well what's work cut it well fellas so
far is this geometric idea of you know
base times height so let's think in
terms of the height of these side
triangles okay so I'm going to use the
height of these things and I'm going to
say that the AIA will be the sum of
three terms which are three bases then
three Heights so let's give names to
these quantities so three for bad it's
going to be good to have the point in
the XY plane that lives directly below P
let's call Q so P is the point a
coordinate X Y and H and let's call Q
the point that's just below it so
coordinates XY 0 okay so let's see let
me draw a picture actually let me draw a
map you know of this link seen from
above so you have p1 p2 p3 I have my
point Q in the middle so let's see to
know these areas I need to know the base
well the base I can decide but I know it
because it's part of my given data right
I know the size of this triangle that we
call the length A to A one A two A three
I also need to know the height so I need
to know these lengths how do I know
these names well
it's a distance in space that's a little
bit annoying but maybe I can reduce it
to a distance in the plane by looking
instead at this distance here okay so
let me give names to the distances from
cue to the sides
okay so let's call u1 u2 and u3 the
distance is on Q to the sides
well now I claim I can find actually
sorry I need to draw one more thing I
claim I have a nice formula for the area
because this side so this is vertical
and that's horizontal so this length
here is UV this length here is H so
what's this length here
yeah it's square root of U V squared
oops plus h squared and similarly for
these other guys there are square roots
of Au square plus h square okay so the
height over faces square root of u 1
square plus h square and similarly with
u2 and u3 so the side the total side
area is going to be well we are the
first faces 1/2 of base times height
plus 1/2 of over base times over height
plus 1/2 of third one doesn't look so
much better but trust me it will get
better ok so now that's a function of
three variables u1 u2 u3 and how do we
relate u1 u2 u3 to each other they're
probably not independent well let's get
this triangle here into three pieces
like that
then
each piece has side well let's look at
say the piece at the bottom it has base
a flea height UV so get the base into
three tells you that the area of the
base is 1/2 of a 1 u 1 plus 1/2 of a 2 u
2 plus 1/2 of a 3 u 3 and that's not
constrained okay so my three variables u
1 u 2 u 3 are constrained in this way
the sum of these three guys must be the
area of the base they want to minimize
that guy so that's my G okay and that
guy here is my F so now if I fight with
Lagrange multiplier equations
well partial F partial u 1 is well if
you do the calculation you will see it's
1/2 a 1 u 1 over square root of u 1
square plus h square should be lambda
times
what's partial G partial you want that
one you can do ensure it's 1/2 a 1 oh
this guy is simplified okay if you do
the same with the second one
things simplify again and same with a
third one well you will get after
simplifying youth way over square root
of u 3 squared plus h square equals
lambda so now that means this guy equals
this guy equals this guy there or equal
to lambda and if you think about it that
means that u 1 equals u 2 equals u 3 see
it looked like scary equations but the
solution is very simple so what does it
mean it means that our point Q should be
equidistant from all three sides that's
called the in-center so Q should be the
in-center so the next time that you have
to build a golden pyramid and don't want
to go block well you know where to put
the top ok if it was a bit fast so I
anyway it's not completely control but
you know go over it you will see it
works have a nice weekend